I'm sitting here with Carl the UX
engineer from Google hey Jay thanks for
having me so Carl let's talk a little
bit about how to get useful feedback
from our users when we're sitting down
with them to test hmm you know so
sitting down with users there's a
variety of ways that we can go about it
I think um I like to start out with when
we're looking at paper I like to start
out kind of an informal setting I like
to leverage folks that are nearby and
involve them in the brainstorming
process as we start to flesh out
features through our prototype okay and
do you start with a task that you want
them to do do you start with just like a
flow the designs do you start with a
blank piece of paper sometimes it's
actually all three it could be any of
the above there are certain times when
you're trying to conceptualize new
features things like that simple
sketching is the right place to start
just drawing boxes and arrows and
circles and things like that on paper is
a really good way to start
especially when you have folks that are
in non design roles um making them feel
comfortable with paper is a really
important part of the prototyping
process but we want to collect as many
ideas as we can so we want to make sure
that we include those folks so paper
sketching is a good way to start
we can then evolve into looking at
specific tasks so we might choose to
prototype a specific task we might
choose to look at a holistic flow we
might choose to do that through a set of
drawings or through high fidelity mocks
maybe that we print out and then we can
walk through your specific screens
within that flow awesome um so pretend
for a moment that I'm a user and I've
sit down with you I how do you get me to
give you the feedback that you need ah
so that's a great question
we'd like to be really really specific
about the feedback that we're looking
for um we really want to make sure that
we don't just leave an open slate lose
when we leave an open slate folks will
tend to focus on maybe design elements
know I don't like the color of that
thing I don't like the position of that
thing and so we want to be very specific
with the feedback that we're looking for
the best thing to do is come up with a
set of directed questions
will lead the user in the direction
you're wanting them to go anyway maybe
through a flow or with a specific screen
okay so you know you'll ask me a set of
directed questions and I'll sort of go
through and talk about them when I'm
stuck or confused you asked me to do a
certain task mm-hmm at what point do you
intervene and say the buttons right here
do you ever do that do you say you know
just let them be confused and recorded
that you're confused about where this
menu button is actually it's a really
good thing to record confusion right so
when a user gets stumped you know we
want to do our best to help them move
through the flow but we also really need
to capture that the user got stumped in
that case the value there is that we can
understand why they got stumped we can
probe just a little bit more understand
the difficulty that they came across
with that UI was a particular affordance
missing is there something that we can
do maybe highlight it with a different
color or make it bigger and make it
bolder or that kind of thing but it also
is good to nudge the user through a flow
if they do become hung up but you want
to progress through the entire test
right you need to address all of the
research questions that you set out with
right um and so letting the user get
stuck and spin in a particular area or
on a particular screen is something that
we want to avoid
so let's talk a little bit about the
questions that we might want to answer
you know we've got you said we need to
go through the entire set of questions
what kinds of questions do we want to be
asking about nap so we've got some
design in our head or on mocks already
what kinds of questions do you want to
be asking about those knocks about that
prototype sure questions will tend to be
very specific to the prototype itself
and so you are gonna look for things
particularly interaction questions might
come out does a user know how to get
from screen a to screen B um do they
know where to find button a and can they
complete a specific task or something
along those lines going through a flow
can they find some of the units maybe
buried three or four screens deep right
those are
types of questions we want to start with
okay perfect so in our example app we
might have questions like can a user
check off this task does a user know
where the menu button is things like
that mm-hmm perfect